unser nächster fall der ist ein ganz
besonders dramatischer per picke seit
acht jahren wird er vermisst die polizei
die glaubt dass der junge verschleppt
wurde und die familie die hat eine ganz
besonders schreckliche befürchtung was
ist wenn pierre gefangen gehalten
geschlagen und missbraucht wird denn es
gibt in dem fall diese eine spur damals
da haben spezielle mantrailer hunde die
fährte aufgenommen und die beamten von
essen über die autobahn bis nach
amsterdam geführt und dort ausgerechnet
ins rotlichtviertel die wie wichtig
diese eine spur ist das besprechen wir
gleich mit hundeführerin alexandra
grunow sie kommt zu uns ins studio mit
ihrem personenspürhund kojak der vor
gerade einmal drei wochen seine letzte
leiche aufgespürt hat aber jetzt erstmal
die recherchen der fall peter parker
der 21-jährige parke aus essen ein
fröhlicher junger mann
er liebt autos freundschaften sind ihm
wichtig er sucht die nähe zu anderen
menschen was man auf den ersten blick
nicht sieht der parke ist geistig
behindert hat die fähigkeiten eines
kleinkindes kann wieder rechnen noch
lesen
wie er kommt als frühchen zur welt bei
der geburt wird sein gehirn mit zu wenig
sauerstoff versorgt die ursache seiner
entwicklungsstörung seine leibliche
mutter stirbt an einem plötzlichen
leberschaden nur einen tag nach seiner
geburt pierre wächst beim vater und
seine stiefmutter auf mit einer
besonders engen bindung zu seinen
großeltern als sein älterer bruder
daniel von zu hause auszieht fühlt sich
pierre zunehmend einsam deshalb
beschließt er im jahr 2012 in ein
wohnheim für menschen mit behinderungen
zu ziehen am 17 september
2013 verschwindet der damals 21-jährige
tierpark von einem supermarktparkplatz
spurlos nicht weit entfernt von seinem
neuen zuhause ein überwachungsvideo aus
einem getränkemarkt ist das letzte
lebenszeichen
hat jemand diesen wehrlosen menschen
verschleppt in gar getötet
an manchen tagen da wacht man morgens
schon auf und kommt einfach nicht mehr
aus den gedanken rasen
seit jahren haben kers eltern deshalb
nur einen wunsch wenn jemand weiß wo er
steckt bitte sagen sie wohl versteckt
weil diese ungewissheit ist fast nicht
mehr auszuhalten
[Musik]
seid ihr verschwinden ist bild
chefreporter frank schneider in engem
kontakt mit den eltern das schicksal
ihres sohnes beschäftigt auch ihn bis
heute
wie es ist möglich dass ein junger mann
mitten in essen am hellichten tag
während des einkaufens vermutlich von
einem supermarktparkplatz verschwindet
[Musik]
wie kann es sein dass ich bis heute bei
der polizei kein zeuge gemeldet hat der
wirklich weiß was mit pierre falke
geschehen ist
und auf die ermittler geben care nicht
auf
die hoffnung tatsächlich habe ich dass
wir noch leben kann das ist nicht
ausgeschlossen
aber es kann im schlimmsten fall terry
auch so sein dass wir schon vor längerer
zeit gestorben ist und wir einfach nicht
finden können
[Musik]
wo ist pia parke der fall des geistig
behinderten hilflosen 21-jährigen bewegt
bis heute viele menschen in essen und
weit über das ruhrgebiet hinaus
bild chefreporter frank schneider und
seine kollegen aus der essener
bildredaktion berichten vom ersten tag
an über den fall
hierauf parkplatz verschwunden angst um
vermissten care
spur führt ins rotlichtviertel von
amsterdam
hier ist es eben so dass ein erwachsener
verschwunden ist der aber das geistige
niveau eines kindes hat und wirklich als
hilflos gilt und die familie sich
deshalb auch von anfang an große sorgen
gemacht es war sehr schnell klar der ist
nicht freiwillig weg diese familie hat
schon soviel schicksal erlebt so viel
elend erlebt jetzt muslimen das auch
noch wieder fahren das hat einen muss
man sagen dass er natürlich nicht kalt
das polizeipräsidium in essen seit acht
jahren laufen hier die fäden im
vermisstenfall parke zusammen
chefreporter frank schneider ist mit
kriminalhauptkommissar ralf menk horst
verabredet auch der ehemalige leiter der
ermittlungskommission ist von anfang an
mit dem fall betraut ich hoffe immer das
war nochmal zu einer lösung kommen das
war entweder per pin oder zumindest ein
ergebnis bekommen wo wir abschließen
können mit der ganzen geschichte klar
gibts tage wo ich nicht daran denke aber
es gibt kein monat ruhig jetzt mal gar
nicht dran denken würde
was ist mit kirkel geschehen
dienstag 17 september 2013 am nachmittag
verlässt peer die heimstatt engelbert in
essen frillendorf eine einrichtung für
menschen mit behinderung in der er seit
mehr als einem jahr lebt das
behindertenwohnheim ist eine offene
einrichtung die bewohner dürfen sich
also auch außerhalb frei bewegen
diesen weg nur 200 meter vom behinderten
wohnheim in essen entfernt gegen peer
parker eigentlich jeden tag er wollte
hierzu dem getränkemarkt auch am tag
seines verschwindens
um fand geld zu bekommen will wie er
hier seine flaschen umtauschen weil
diese wie so häufig noch halb voll sind
kommt es zu einer diskussion mit der
verkäuferin
frustriert packt er seine flaschen
wieder in seinen rucksack und verlässt
den getränkemarkt eine
überwachungskamera filmt genau diesen
moment die letzten aufnahmen von care
park
das sind bilder die ihnen da noch mal
zeigen auch in seiner typischen art wie
er sich bewegt hat eben auch seine
bekleidung die wir dort sehen die
letzten punkte von ihnen er kann
aufgrund seiner behinderung wieder lesen
noch rechnen oft ist der
orientierungslos sein weg führt ihn an
diesem tag noch weiter zu einem
supermarkt er will sich neue getränke
kaufen doch auch dieser besuch endet
erfolglos sein geld reicht nicht wie
eine zeugen später berichtet es ist kurz
nach 19 uhr als wir an der katze in
diesem penny supermarkt versucht mit
einem alten netto kassenzettel zu
bezahlen auch hier wird er abgewiesen
enttäuscht und niedergeschlagen verlässt
er den supermarkt zwischen 19 15 und 20
uhr was dann geschieht ist bis heute
unklar
diesen laden dort durch die tür
verlassen da ist die ausfahrt richtung
autobahn dann könnte also theoretisch
haben ihr stehen genau an der stelle wo
er möglicherweise auf den täter
getroffen das könnte tatsächlich so sein
also wir sehen hier ein bereich ja auch
ein industriegebiet hier sind
verschiedene geschäfte hier verstanden
auch verschiedene fahrzeuge auf diesem
parkplatz verlassen hin wieder und
ihr könnt alles passiert sein
deshalb will die polizei wissen wer hat
am 17 september 2013 zwischen 19 15 und
20uhr tierpark rund um den penny
supermarkt in der ersten straße in essen
frillendorf gesehen wer hat beobachtet
wie er möglicherweise in ein auto
gestiegen ist und weggefahren wurde
grundsätzlich war
begeistert von autos und hat sich auch
im heim gerne solche sachen belohnen
lassen also es war so eine eine geste
dort das wenn was etwas gut gelaufen ist
oder was gut gelaufen ist dass er dann
mit einem auto mitfahren durften das
fand aber toll und insofern ist das
natürlich auch ein einfallstor gewesen
für einen täter
aufgrund seiner geistigen behinderung
behandelt die essener polizei den fall
park wie die vermisstensache eines
kindes auch die bild zeitung berichtet
sofort über den fall
wir haben sehr schnell davon erfahren
weil die familie so einen tag danach
schon selber sucht plakate aufgehangen
hat mit ihren handy nummern dadurch hat
eine sehr sehr schnell kontakt zur
familie auch der kontakt zur polizei ist
hier war und sehr vertrauensvoll und gut
und deswegen habe ich auch sehr schnell
kontakt zur polizei aufgenommen und dort
war die sorge auch sofort sehr groß
schnell war klar dass sich peer nicht
einfach verlaufen hat die polizei bildet
umgehend eine ermittlungskommission
sucht mit hochdruck befragt mitarbeiter
von krankenhäusern öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln an taxis hundertschaften
durchkämmen die umgebung rund um den ort
des verschwindens suchen auch intensiv
in diesem waldstück unweit des penny
supermarktes nachdem wir sämtliche
suchmaßnahmen befragungen im näheren
umfeld
erfolglos beenden mussten haben wir
weiter überlegt wo er sein könnte es
gibt die möglichkeit halt mit suchhunden
jemanden auf zu finden bzw dessen spur
zu verfolgen das haben wir in diesem
fall auch mit den sogenannten mantrailer
hunden gemacht und dann sind wir im
grunde ohne eine eine richtung
losgegangen und wann man sehr überrascht
wo diese hunde uns hin geführt haben
wo ist hier parken der 21 jährige wurde
zuletzt am 17 september 2013 in diesem
penny supermarkt im essener stadtteil
frillendorf gesehen
kerr ist seit seiner geburt behindert
hat die geistigen fähigkeiten eines
kleinkindes hat jemand diesem wehrlosen
menschen etwas angetan oder ihn entführt
wird hier gefangen gehalten
da kann man nur hoffen dass da jemand
der weiß die kraft hat zu sagen was es
ist weil dann müssen wir nun mit einer
wahren leben auch die ermittler suchen
seit mittlerweile acht jahren nach neuen
spuren und hinweisen vergeblich anfang
oktober 2013 der vermeintliche
durchbruch
mantrailer hunde der polizei die gezielt
nach vermissten personen suchen führen
die ermittler auf eine erste heiße spur
ganz in der nähe von pias
behindertenwohnheim schlagen die hunde
an einem auto und einer wohnung an und
sowohl der halter des fahrzeugs als auch
der mieter der wohnung sind wegen
sexuellen missbrauchs vorbestraft
haben aufwendig versucht auch in der
wohnung spurensuche zu betreiben und
hinweise zu finden ob es eine verbindung
gegeben hat das kommt man so aber nie
nachvollziehen und entsprechend keine
beweislage schaffen die dazu geführt hat
dass der mann dringend tatverdächtig
gewesen sein könnte aber ausschließen
kann man es auch nicht
ganz ausschließen können was nicht wenn
da kein geständnis kommt oder eine
eigene einlassungen über in details noch
nicht hatten können wir das nicht
beweisen und dann sind wir genau so
schlau wie zuvor
die hunde führen die ermittler aber noch
zu einer anderen stelle die ehemalige
autobahnauffahrt in essen frillendorf
nur wenige hundert meter von kers
wohnheim entfernt begonnen hat die spur
unweit von hier im bereich seines
wohnheims und bei den letzten
aufenthaltsorten den verschiedenen
getränkemärkten da haben wir ja am
letzten parkplatz eine spur dass wir
sagen da wissen wir nichts mehr und dann
sind wir hier hingekommen also ist die
vermutung dass er dort ein auto
gestiegen ist und dieses dann
weitergegangen
genau wissen wir es natürlich nicht aber
letztlich müssen wir davon ausgehen dass
er mit einem auto wie auch immer ein pkw
einen lkw auf dieser autobahn gekommen
ist und eine fortbewegung zu fuß schade
dem wohnhaus
die hunde verfolgen die geruchsspur
sogar über die autobahn a 40 richtung
duisburg und über die a 3 richtung
arnheim bis nach amsterdam ins
rotlicht-milieu hier verliert sich die
spur
wir hatten einen bereich in amsterdam wo
wir gedacht haben dort könnte er oder
dort wird er gewesen sein wir haben auch
dort hinweise versucht zu bekommen und
die niederländer haben auch eigene
ermittlungen angestellt letztlich
konnten die uns aber auch nicht am ende
eine eine heiße spur bringen und wir
haben kein lebenszeichen von care in den
niederlanden finden können
[Musik]
der schreckliche verdacht wurde hier von
menschenhändlern verschleppt wird ein
hilfloser mensch zur prostitution
gezwungen missbraucht oder gefangen
gehalten
wir waren ja auch in gar nicht so da und
wir haben alles getan wir waren aber wir
haben waren im rotlichtmilieu wir waren
überall der bilder aus plakat verteilt
und haben auch die prostituierten alle
anderen befragt auch keiner konnte sagen
die angst ist ganz klar dass er dagegen
sein film sex klar
nach der hoffnung der rückschlag alle
hinweise sind abgearbeitet die spuren
überprüft die ermittlungskommission wird
eingestellt der fall pierre park wird
zum korb case
[Musik]
ich habe immer die erfahrung gemacht
wenn jemand ermordet wird das ist das
ganz grauenhaftes und schrecklich ist
aber die menschen haben irgendwann die
chance mit ihrer trauer zu beginnen weil
sie wissen dann was passiert es
spätestens im prozess so brutal auch
manchmal die details sind aber die
familien haben irgendwann einen punkt wo
sie mit ihrer trauer verarbeitung
beginnen können das ist in 29 fällen
häufig überhaupt nicht so weil man ja
überhaupt nichts weiß und auch
vielleicht die sorge immer noch zu
glauben fällt mein kind noch wird seit
jahren gefangen gehalten und ich glaube
dass es was viel mehr zermürbt als
vielleicht eine grausame gewissheit
deshalb geben sie alle nicht auf die
bild-reporter die ermittler
und die familie
wenn jemand weiß wo er steckt bitte
sagen sie wohl versteckt auch wenn er
nicht mehr leben sollte bitte
die brauchen der polizei einen anonymen
tipp geben das würde ja schon reichen
darüber hinaus will die polizei wissen
wer hat die attacke am 17 september 2013
in der zeit nach 19.15 noch gesehen der
park ist 1 75 groß schlank hat blonde
haare und blaue augen am tag seines
verschwindens trug er einen
cremefarbenen kapuzen pulli mit
schwarzen streifen an den ärmeln und
aufdruck auf der linken vorderen seite
dazu ein dunkles t shirt mit gelben
aufdruck weiße turnschuhe mit
klettverschluss er trug einen hellblauen
rucksack mit breiten riemen
wem ist am 17 september 2013 zwischen 19
15 und 20 uhr rund um den parkplatz des
penny supermarktes in der
industriestraße in essen frillendorf
etwas ungewöhnliches aufgefallen oder
hat gesehen wie peter parker in ein auto
eingestiegen ist und weggefahren wurde
wer hat am 17 september 2013 oder in den
tagen danach in oder auf dem weg in die
niederlande
speziell in amsterdam beobachtungen
gemacht die möglicherweise mit dem
verschwinden tierparkes in zusammenhang
stehen könnten hinweise bitte an die
polizei essen unter 0201
polizei essen bittet in dem
vermisstenfall der parke noch mal darum
dass sich zeugen melden die
feststellungen gemacht haben die wir neu
bewerten können in der heutigen zeit und
mit der wir vielleicht den fall
abschließen können
ob täter mitwisser bruder zeugen melden
sie sich bei der essener polizei die
eltern und großeltern von care zahlen
für sachdienliche hinweise die zum
auffinden von care führen zusätzlich
eine belohnung in höhe von
15.000 euro
das alles damit aus dem cold case pierre
parke nach acht jahren ein aufgeklärter
fall wird
bei uns im studio ist jetzt alexandra
grunow mit ihrem spüren kojak hallo
schön dass sie da sind high sie haben
mir vorher gesagt im vorgespräch das
kojak in den vergangenen drei jahren 55
mal erfolgreich war soll sie einmal was
bedeutet dass erfolgreich seien bei ihm
bei ihm heißt ist dass er entweder leben
findet direkt oder tod findet direkt
oder uns den fall aufklärt in dem sinne
dass er uns sagt wo was wie weiter
ermittelt werden kann und dass das dann
auch zum erfolg bringt also kommt gibt
es bei diesen 55 erfolgreichen fällen
einer wo sie sagen an denen erinnern sie
sich besonders der sticht heraus
der ist sogar davor passiert also ich
hab jetzt noch mal die drei jahre mit
dem 55 fällen gehabt der war noch davor
das war sehr spektakulär weil das der
faschingsprinz in münchen war und er
hatte seine frau als vermisst gemeldet
und wir sind dazu gekommen weil die
reinigung der vermisstensache ging das
kommt öfters mal vor und wir haben dann
die hunde angesetzt mit einem gruß
artikel an dem platz wo ihr auto geparkt
war und mit ihrem geruch und die hunde
sind nicht gelaufen also da war um das
auto drumherum aber nicht mehr angesagt
das gibt es doch nicht weil irgendwo
muss eine spur seien von ihr wenn sie
dort war sodann haben wir geruch noch
mal aus der wohnung geholt und das war
dann geruch von ihm und ihr mich geruch
aus der wäsche truhe und haben den
hunden den zu richten gegeben und
plötzlich liefen die hunde und sie
liefen aber auf diesen misch geruch aber
nichts was man dachte zur bahn weil das
auto war in jeder bar angepackt sondern
richtung nach hause und dann sind wir
eigentlich fast zu hause angekommen
gesagt das kann nicht sein und dann
haben wir in dem augenblick heraus ja
einfach gedacht was hat er damit zu tun
und dann haben wir ein großer titel von
ihm bekommen eindeutigen in der
zwischenzeit versucht sich das leben zu
nehmen weil wir ihm auf die spur
gekommen sind und die hunde haben dann
eindeutig quasi festgestellt dass er das
auto dort gefragt hat und von dort aus
nach hause gelaufen war und ja er hatte
seine frau vorher ermordet in das auto
gepackt weggefahren wald vergraben und
dann das auto dort hingestellt und das
nach hause gelaufen und hat sie als
vermisst gemeldet sie haben es gerade
mehrfach geruchs artikel gesagt was
genau bedeutet ist das ein t shirt eine
socke was was nimmt man da genau also
teilweise nehmen wir sogar die
innensohle vom schuh
t shirt kann sein dass ich ja vorbei
gegangen ist und eine fälschung geruch
drauf das heißt so wirklich eindeutig
sauber von dem vermissten ist manchmal
die schuhsohle also innen drin weil
dafür ist keiner drin sei es im
pflegeheim oder sonstwo nehmen wir eben
etwas was wirklich nach der person nicht
ausschließlich jetzt liegt hier vor uns
hat sich geworden macht gut so für ihn
was zeichnet ihn denn aus was hat er
gelernt dass er so überragend menschen
und vermisste aufspüren kann also er
kann besonders alte spuren arbeiten er
kann besonders mit minimal geruch
arbeiten und er ist einfach extrem
hartnäckig gibt nicht auf er will den
fall lösen nimmt uns mit er ist ein
richtiger anführer und das zeichnet ihn
aus dass sie sich nicht beeinflussen
lässt von irgendwas jetzt haben wir hier
über den fall gesprochen und eben diesen
ansatz den die ermittler haben das
damals spezielle mantrailer hunde eben
die fährte aufgenommen haben über die
autobahn bis nach amsterdam wie muss man
sich das vorstellen was genau riechen
die hunde da durch das geschlossene auto
an der straße was wie funktioniert das
also lange zeit haben wir gedacht auch
dass der hund eigentlich nur das auto
von dem tatsächlich vermissten auch
riechen kann also wenn er in sein auto
einsteigt und wegfährt das ist so viel
geruch jetzt einfach mal geruch geruchs
partikel an diesem auto auch draußen
dran in der lüftung dass es ausreicht
aus der hund die spur verfolgen kann
damit haben wir auch wenig probleme wenn
der vermissten ein fremd auto einsteigt
oder in den bus oder so dann tun sich
die hunde schwerer tatsächlich das
verfolgen zu können weil das auto nicht
den geruch von der person hat also das
wird immer weniger immer immer
schwieriger und je schneller das auto
fährt umso weiter komplizierter wird
dass
das ist immer kann man sagen kann
funktionieren muss nicht 100 prozent
funktionieren ja das ist immer eine
heikle geschichte aber man muss die
hunde speziell darauf trainieren ja dass
die mit so wenig partikel wirklich ein
umzugehen und nicht jeder kann sich voll
gefahren kann das grundsätzlich ich
hatte 13 jahre lang und über hätte der
das lernen können oder
ja es hat nicht die rasse aus sondern
die art des trainings und es wird ja
immer behauptet hunde können nicht
besonders alt und dann nach 24 stunden
jetzt nicht mehr ist totaler quatsch
also er hat vor vier vor drei wochen so
was in vier wochen vermissten gefunden
in 25 minuten auto war geparkt wir haben
ihn verfolgt und dort gefunden ja also
das ist nachweislich erwiesen dass es
funktioniert aber es ist eine trainings
sache und wenn man falsch trainiert oder
anders trainiert dann können die hunde
das auch nicht ich würde sie gerne zum
abschluss noch fragen wie ist das wenn
sie also mit ihm zusammen durch den wald
suchen suchen suchen und dann stößt man
auf den vermissten aber der ist tot wie
ist das für sie persönlich
ich habe zum glück meinen hund dabei und
der ist dann mein therapeut gleich man
kann sich um den hund kümmern weil für
ihn ist das auch ein thema also tot ist
nicht so dass er sagt die who ich habe
das gefunden was ich suche sondern er
ist das auch unangenehm und ich helfe
ihm dann er hilft mir und damit haben
wir trotzdem er auch einen erfolg weil
wir das gefunden haben was wir gesucht
haben und ja wir unterstützen uns dann
gegenseitig tonfilm vielen dank dass sie
heute bei uns waren zusammen mit jack in
beiden viel erfolg für die zukunft
und eben im fall der parke da ist es so
dass eben egal ob täter und mitwisser ob
zeugen helfen sie per und vor allem
helfen sie der familie endlich
gewissheit zu haben und eben im
schlimmsten fall auch abschließen zu
können haben sie pierre gesehen wissen
sie was mit ihm in amsterdam geschehen
ist hinweise nimmt die kriminalpolizei
essen unter 0201
8290 entgegen und pias familie hat auch
eine belohnung ausgesetzt 30.000 euro
für den entscheidenden hinweis zur
aufklärung des falls